Dear friends, in today's video,
we will explore a fundamental problem
of philosophy: the
phenomena of the world can be divided into two types:
material phenomena and
mental phenomena. Matter and consciousness are two
philosophical concepts used to refer to these two types of
phenomena. So, how are matter or existence
and consciousness or spirit, or thought,
related? Which comes
first, which comes after, and which determines
which?
While philosophical theories are very diverse,
every theory must answer
questions about this relationship, considering it a
fundamental problem of philosophy. According to
Engels, the great fundamental problem of all
philosophy, especially modern philosophy, is the
problem of the relationship between thought and existence. The
fundamental problem of philosophy has two
aspects: firstly, between consciousness and
matter, which comes first, which comes after, and
which determines which.
Depending on how this question is answered,
different philosophical schools have
divided into two basic movements:
materialism and idealism.
Materialism asserts that matter
precedes consciousness; the material world
exists objectively, independently of
human consciousness, and is not created by anyone. Consciousness
is a reflection of the objective world
in the human brain; there can be no
conscious spirit without matter.
Materialism has a long history with
many different forms.
Its first form is ancient materialism,
which is primitive materialism.
This materialism originated from
nature to explain the world.
It arose from the need to form
scientific knowledge and from the struggle
of the liberal class against the ruling aristocratic class.
This form of materialism lacked a scientific basis
to withstand the attacks of
idealism and religion that dominated the Middle Ages. From the Renaissance
to the
Renaissance, the bourgeoisie emerged and built
materialism to counter the
idealistic and religious worldview of the feudal
landlord class. This is the second form
of materialism, but due to
limitations in the level of scientific understanding...  Learning and being
controlled by class interests,
17th-18th century materialism was metaphysical materialism,
built upon the
foundation of modern science. Dialectical materialism,
especially
historical materialism, is the highest form of
materialism in its entirety.
Materialism was born and developed in
close connection with the development
of productive labor and
scientific knowledge, in the struggle against
religious reformism and
reactionary forces for social progress. Idealism, in opposition to
materialism,
argues that consciousness
precedes and is the basis of the existence of nature
and matter. Idealism is
divided into two main schools:
subjective idealism and objective idealism. Subjective idealism
argues that human consciousness
is what precedes and determines the existence
of all things and phenomena.
Things and phenomena are merely
sensory constructs or complex particles of
sensation—colors, smells, tastes, and
various characteristics.  Things
are merely human sensations, the
feelings of the ego;
this idealist conception inevitably leads to egoism, a
philosophy stemming from the ego. Objective idealism, on the other hand,
posits that consciousness, the
absolute idea, the absolute spirit,
or reason—the world—exists before the material
world. This spiritual entity
exists objectively,
independent of humans and humankind, and
determines the existence of nature,
society, and human thought. All things and
phenomena in nature and society
are embodiments of consciousness. Objective
idealism and subjective idealism,
though differing in expression, are fundamentally similar in that
both, in one way or another,
share the objective origin of the natural world
and matter. That is, both
acknowledge the spirit and consciousness as creators of the
world. In this respect, idealism is
close to religion and ultimately always
defends or supports religion.
Idealism has
epistemological and social origins.  The
epistemological origin of Neo-Consciousness is the
absolutization of the role of
consciousness. Lenin clearly pointed this out:
philosophical idealism is a development, an
exaggeration, an overemphasis on
one of the characteristics of
consciousness, making it an
absolute detachment from matter, from nature, and
from the spiritual realm. Lenin
bluntly affirmed that linearity and one-sidedness, rigidity
and
inflexibility, subjectivism and blind subjectivism
are the
epistemological origins of idealism. The
social origin of idealism
is the formation and development of
classes opposed to each other in interests, the
emergence of a division of labor between intellectual
and manual labor after the separation of
manual labor and intellectual labor, which has a
relatively independent position and becomes the
privilege of the exploiting class.
Therefore, the thinkers of
that class have a contemptuous attitude towards manual labor
and mistakenly believe that
intellectual labor determines the existence and
development of society.  The aforementioned errors and deviations
of the idealist worldview have been
exploited by reactionary forces to
protect and safeguard the interests of the
ruling class.
Lenin pointed out the
inevitable errors in the theoretical understanding of idealism, which
will inevitably lead to a quagmire of
secularism, and will certainly be reinforced by the
class interests of the ruling classes.
Besides the two basic currents,
materialism and idealism, in philosophy there is also the
Dualist school. The Dualist school
argues that both material
and spiritual principles exist simultaneously and
independently of each other. The material system gives
rise to material phenomena, and the
spiritual system gives rise to spiritual phenomena.
However, ultimately, the Dualist school
is also a form of reform because it
acknowledges that consciousness is formed and developed
independently of matter. The second aspect
of the fundamental problem of philosophy is that
when humans have the ability to perceive
the world, materialist philosophers,
starting from the idea that matter
precedes consciousness and is a reflection
of matter, affirm human capacity.  While
some modernist philosophers acknowledge the possibility of knowing the world, they
argue that consciousness
precedes matter and matter depends on
consciousness. Therefore, they believe that knowledge
is not a reflection of the world but rather
self-awareness, a conscious awareness of consciousness itself.
A segment of idealist philosophers, however,
rejected the principle that
humans can know the world. These are the
philosophers of the
unknowable doctrine. Lenin pointed
out that these
unknowable philosophers often attempt to occupy an
intermediate position between materialism
and idealism, yet they consistently
deny the external world as the
objective content of human cognitive representation.
Thus, any
philosophical doctrine or system
must address the fundamental problem of
philosophy. Based on how
this fundamental problem is solved, philosophers are
divided into two schools: materialism and
idealism. All other philosophical problems
are addressed from either the
idealist or the materialist standpoint.